- I just grabbed her, I kept
bangin' her fuckin' head.
"I don't give a fuck,
you fuck.
I'm--" and I know, I know a lot
of you motherfuckers like,
"Joey, you can't hit a woman--"
She's a fuckin' nun.
Big fuckin' difference, okay?
Big fuckin' difference.
[engine revs]
[dark electronic music]
♪
[mouthing words]
[gunshot]
[heart beating]
[roars]
[gunshots]
[growls]
[roars]
[cheers and applause]
- He's one of my best friends in
the world.
You guys'll love him.
He's awesome.
Ladies and gentleman,
Joey Diaz.
[cheers and applause]
- I got a three-year-old, you
know, and I look at her.
She's beautiful. I look at her,
and I'm like,
"You know, when she gets older,
I don't think I'll have the
heart to fucking smack her to
discipline her."
You know what I'm saying?
Like, I throw, like,
a sneaker at the cat from time
to time and shit like that.
When I look at my daughter, I
don't have the heart.
Like, I look at her, like, I
could probably punish her
and send her to her room, but
can I fucking hit her?
No, like, I don't think I have
the balls to do it.
But they always say that if you
grew up in a house
that you got fucked up at that
you'll probably have a house
that you fuck people up at.
You know, like, if your
parents--and I'll tell you what.
I grew up in the '70s.
My mom fucked me up, okay?
My mom fucked me up.
Not like fuck--it was as a
controlled beating, okay?
Let's get this shit straight.
Everybody in this room got a
controlled beating at one time.
That means you're not gonna
fucking die, okay?
You know, you're gonna get a
couple punches to the head,
you'll go down, and in two days,
you get a doll.
No big fucking deal.
That's a controlled fucking
beating, all right?
You're not gonna die, you know?
And when I was a kid, you know,
I used to bust my mom's balls,
and, you know, she's Cuban and,
you know, a single mom,
and she would lose her temper
from time to time.
And, you know, you get, like, my
mom would hit me with, like,
the straight punch to the head,
the fucking overhead right.
In Spanish, it's called...
[speaks Spanish]
It means a fucking airplane.
And then they had, like,
different names to them.
Then they have the fucking...
[speaks Spanish]
That's the bitch slap.
You know, that's the Stockton
slap, right?
And then my mom had the
backhand.
[speaks Spanish.]
That's just to throw you off to
open you--yeah.
It opens you up for a sidekick
to the body, right?
That's what that does.
You're like, "Ahh," bam, and all
of a sudden,
you get kicked and shit,
so I took a beating.
Listen, my mom threw a beating
on me one time on 86th Street
when I was, like, six, 'cause I
wouldn't get off a mule
in front of--there's a bank on
86th and Broadway,
and I--there was a mule, some
fucking dude with a mule,
and you give him, like, $3, and
he'd put a cowboy hat on you,
you know, and let you get on the
fucking mule with a vest and
shit, and I wouldn't get off the
mule.
My mother beat the fuck out of
my with her purse.
That was a good one, like, a
live appearance-type beating.
You don't get those.
But that was it.
Like, as I got older,
I never really got hit, and my
mom was single,
and my mama would always tell
me, "Don't ever let nobody
"touch your face; a really man
doesn't let nobody
"touch their face.
Don't let nobody
fucking touch your face."
So being Cuban, I was also
Catholic,
so my mom
would scare me with the nuns.
She'd go, you fuck up, I'm
gonna send you to school, and
those nuns will fuck you up.
Well, after torturing my mom
for a few years, she said,
fuck it, I'm puttin' you
in Catholic school, I'll let
the nuns deal with you.
And I think my mom knew the nuns
were gonna fuck me up.
She just didn't want to know.
You know what I'm saying?
Like, she was like, they're
gonna fuck you up,
but I don't wanna know about it.
So it was one of those schools--
Sacred Heart School for Boys--
you went on Sunday, and you came
home on Thursdays.
And the nuns were complete
fuckin' douchebags.
I mean, complete douchebags.
And I'm not lying, I don't give
a fuck if you don't--
it's the truth, they were
fuckin'--
I think about it now,
30 years later, and it really
was mild abuse.
It was very mild--I could've
dialed 911 on those bitches,
but, you know,
nobody would've listened to my
cries, you understand me?
They say nuns don't--whatever,
so there was this one nun,
Sister Anna, there was Sister
Marie,
there was Sister Heissons,
and there was Sister--some--
Sister Patricia.
Sister fucking Heissons was the
most evil person
that ever walked the fucking
face of the Earth.
They didn't hit me at that
school
'cause I was a bad person.
They used to hit me 'cause I
didn't like milk.
Till this fucking day--listen,
to this day,
I fucking hate milk, okay?
I'm not allergic to it.
I just don't fucking like it.
That's it.
A milkshake, completely fucking
different.
I'll drink ten of those
motherfuckers.
But milk plain out of a bottle,
I don't like that shit.
It smells like dick.
I don't fucking like it.
That's it.
I've never fucking liked it.
I don't like broccoli then.
I don't like them now.
I don't give a fuck.
I don't like it.
But they would abuse me.
If I didn't drink the milk,
they'd put it on my head
and then bitch slap me, like,
three fucking times.
And then when I went down, she
hit me with the tray of food.
These people were fucking
savages.
And this one fuckin' nun, Sister
Heissons--she's New Jersey,
she looks just like Governor
Christie, all fucked up.
She was like 5'2", 310--
the bitch didn't fuck around.
And if you look at a nun, they
have a fuckin' ring of Jesus.
They're married to Jesus.
And before she'd hit you, she'd
turn it around,
and that's how they'd fuckin'
cut you and shit like that.
No, and these nuns don't
fuck around, guys.
This is real old-school fuckin'
Catholicism, and, no,
no, I wasn't molested--I was an
ugly kid, they didn't fuck
with me,
you know what I'm sayin'?
Fuck you. I was an altar boy,
but I never hung out.
Fuck you.
I don't want to play cards,
and I don't want no hard ice
cream, cocksucker.
I'm a Carvel motherfucker
anyway.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm a Carvel motherfucker.
Fuck that hard ice cream, bitch.
Fuck you think you're dealing
with?
I got morals.
You know what I'm saying?
So I'm in the fuckin' fifth
grade, I'd been there
for like three years--
not in the fuckin' fifth grade,
I had--I had been at the school
fuckin' three years.
I started in the third grade,
and I stayed there till
the fifth, but there was
a reason why, and I didn't know,
I didn't know if I was like 30 I
wanted to make my Confirmation.
I'm like, why am I makin' my
Confirmation at 30?
And I remembered this story,
this is why.
Because in the fifth grade,
I couldn't take it no more.
Now, my dad died when I was
three, so my parent--my mom
at the time put me in kung-fu,
like karate with the brothers,
these black motherfuckers
on 90th Street.
And they would teach you like
ghetto karate, like fuckin'
judo and shit,
I was out of my mind.
Between that and Bruce Lee,
I was ready to kill
a motherfucker,
you know what I'm sayin'?
And Bruce Lee had died, and I
was all fucked in the head,
and my dad had died.
And between the pain and the
fuckin' low self-esteem and the
anger, I was boilin' inside.
And one day, I'm in the fuckin'
Catholic school, and they're
these two little twins,
they're like half mo-mos,
Rafael and Nino,
you know what I'm sayin'?
They're fuckin' cryin', I'm
like, "What're you cryin' for?"
They go, "Sister Heissons--
My mommy's having a baby,
and Sister Heissons won't let us
call the hospital."
And I'm like, "You know, not for
nothing.
Jesus don't pay for these
fucking lights."
[laughter]
"Your mom and dad do.
Get up.
"Just go call your fucking mom.
It's an emergency."
And the nun, Sister Heissons,
heard us, and she goes, "Really?
All three of youse,
go outside and wait."
Now, when a nun told you to wait
outside the class,
that means you were getting
a fuckin' beating, like you're
getting the shit knocked out
of you, all right?
So the bell rings...
the bell rings,
you know, she comes out,
she goes,
so what did you three guys--
what were you talkin' about?
And there were two twins;
she took the one twin first,
smacked the fuck out of him
like 15 times, he went down.
[laughter]
She went to grab me, and I'm
like, I'm lookin' at the twin,
I'm like, "That's your brother,
get in there,
motherfucker," right?
"Why am I fighting for you?
Get in there, you fuck."
She grabbed him, fucked his
world up,
and then she grabbed me,
and started bitch-slappin' me.
But I kept thinking about my
mom.
I got sick and tired of this
motherfucker hitting me
every time I wouldn't drink my
milk, and I was about to snap,
so I put my hands up, and she's
bitin' her tongue--
I'll never forget this--goin',
put your hands down,
put your hands down.
I'm like, fuck, you've
gotta work for it,
you know what I'm sayin'?
I ain't puttin' shit down.
She's hittin' me in the fuckin'
temple.
This bitch is fucking me up.
So finally she goes, "You're not
gonna put your hands down,
then get in the utility closet."
That's basically where they
fucking killed you right there.
They just fucking killed you,
then they called your mother
and said, "He died of
pneumonia," and that was it.
Creep motherfuckers, those
Catholics.
I'm telling you right now.
I'd look behind the curtain.
They're creepy motherfuckers.
So she says, "Get in the utility
closet."
That's where they had, like, the
books and the fucking
protractors and all that shit.
So we get in there, and she
fucking doesn't even
slam the door, guy.
She just fuckin' japs me right
in the mouth, like...
[speaks Spanish]
And I feel the blood, but I put
my hand up, and she's like,
"Don't you ever tell on me," and
she's just smackin' me, guy.
She's just going at it, bam,
bam, and she had elbows.
She had kicks. This is way
before "UFC Unleashed."
This bitch is going off.
She's kicking my legs to lower
my hands,
and she's smackin' me.
I'll tell you what, guys, I--I,
you know, I was fuckin' pissed.
I--I couldn't believe this lady
was doin' this to me.
And at one point, I go,
I'm--I'm gonna fuckin'
take this bitch out.
I'm just gonna take this
motherfucker out.
I don't give a fuck.
But if I go for her,
I gotta fuckin' go for it.
'cause she's 320.
You following me?
I'm, like, 100 with a
crucifix in pocket.
If I go for it, I got to go for
this motherfucker.
So finally, she's like,
"Put your hands down."
I wouldn't put 'em down,
but I started tastin' the blood
in my mouth, and I started
fuckin' losin' it,
and something just made me go,
I'm gonna go for this
motherfucker, but I'm gonna
grab her by the ears,
and I grabbed her by the veil,
'cause that's where all
the magic powers are, right?
I grabbed her by the fuckin'
veil, and I'm like, "Don't you
"ever fuckin' hit me again,
you cocksucker!
I hate you!"
And I'm just cryin'.
This is seven years of anger
and pain--I missed father;
what's goin' on in my house?
I just grabbed her, I kept
bangin' her fuckin' head.
"I don't give a fuck,
you fuck. I'm--"
And I know, I know a lot of you
motherfuckers like, "Joey,
you can't hit a woman--"
She's a fuckin' nun.
Big fuckin' difference, okay?
Big fuckin' difference.
She don't suck no cock, they
don't take it in the ass,
these motherfuckers are angry,
all right?
They don't eat no pussy.
They just walk around
with a fuckin' black suit on.
Something's got to be done.
It's fucked up.
You got to eat something.
You know what I'm saying?
You're walking around like
somebody died.
Yeah, your fucking pussy, that's
what died.
[laughter]
So I got her by the fuckin' ears
now, and I ain't lettin' go,
because I know she's gonna
fuck my world up.
And I'm poundin', poundin',
poundin', but the black dudes,
they taught me judo, too.
So I went to give her like
a hip throw, but she's 320, I
couldn't do it, so I just
settled on a headlock,
and I'm grabbin' her by
the fuckin' head, and I'm
squeezin', and she's goin',
"You're gonna go to hell!"
And I'm like, "So the fuck
are you, motherfucker!"
And I'm squeezin'
her fuckin' head,
"Fuck you!
Fuck you!"
And finally, there was a little
mad mafia kid--
thank God for
fuckin' Italian people.
Thank God for fuckin' Italian
people.
They don't give a fuck about
the rules or nothin'.
This guy's like,
"What's goin' on?"
I go, "This bitch
tried to kill me."
And he's like,
"Fuck this bitch."
He took her arm, and he twisted
this motherfucker.
I got her in a headlock,
this little eight-year-old's
twisting her fuckin' arm,
and she's like "Ahh!"
And we don't give a fuck.
The other nuns are around.
But lemme tell ya what happened.
Now, the door was open,
and there was a bunch of kids,
and they're yellin',
"Coco! Coco! Coco!"
Now I gotta kill her--
you understand me?
There ain't no turnin'
fuckin' back.
[laughter]
So we take her out of the
utility closet.
They're yelling, "Call the
police."
I'm like, "Call the police.
I'm fuckin' bleeding.
I don't give a fuck.
Call the cops."
We're twisting her.
The kids are coming over.
They're kicking her and shit.
It's--the Puerto Ricans too.
They don't give a fuck either.
A couple Roberto Clemente
motherfuckers
kicking her and shit.
[laughs]
[laughter]
So I don't know nothin'.
I don't fuckin' know nothin'.
They call the police.
The kids are clapping.
It's fuckin' crazy.
We're taking over the whole
fuckin' hallway.
And I go, "Fuck it, let's call
my mother."
So we drag this nun in a half
a armbar and a headlock,
and we took her shoes off.
I don't know why till today.
300--she had those big fuckin'
fat feet
with no nail polish and shit.
We took the feet out from under
her and just dragged her.
Her head was turning red, and
one of the Puerto Ricans
called the number and put it
to my ear, and I called my mom,
Mima...
[speaks Spanish]
That means the nun hit me.
Let me tell ya somethin'--
Kearny, New Jersey, is about
22 minutes from inner-city
New Jersey--my mother made it
in eight minutes.
She shows up with eight Puerto
Ricans
and a Santería
priest with a live chicken--
you understand me?
That's when shit
goes down motherfucker.
So they finally got me off the
fuck.
She's--her hair's fucked up.
The veil's off.
My mom's telling her, "You want
to hit my son,
"you've got to get fucked in the
ass and have your own kid,"
and all this shit.
I'm loving it.
My mom got my back and shit.
So now we're sitting down,
people are holding on to their
heads,
got the priest in the room, the
principal,
and they tell my mom, "He's out,
him and his other fucking
cohorts,"
like, eight of us, "They're
fucking out of here."
And my mom's listening to this.
She's got half a bag on.
She's a little drunk and shit.
And she's like, "He ain't goin'
fuckin' nowhere."
And they're like, "No, he's got
to go. He's out of here."
Listen, when I was growing up,
there was this Jew bookie
in the neighborhood, tremendous.
Let me tell you something.
Thank God for Jewish people.
[laughter]
All right, this motherfucker was
a bookie,
but in the early '70s, if you
beat him for, like, $2,000 or
$3,000, he would show up at your
house with $500 bills.
And he'd say to you, "You want
me to pay you, I'll pay you,
but I've got to give you 500s."
"Ahh, let it roll till next
week."
Then the next week, he got you.
You following me?
So he always had your fucking
money.
He would just lie to you that he
had $500 bills.
Who the fuck has, like, a $500
bill.
People would believe it; that's
an old Jew trick right there.
Let me tell you what my...
[laughter]
You got to learn; you got to
fuckin' learn, cocksuckers.
[laughter]
He goes to throw my mom out,
and my mom goes,
"Listen, he ain't goin' nowhere,
or I want my deposit back in
fives."
That's an old Jew trick too.
It blew their mind.
"Fives?"
[laughter]
"We don't have no fuckin' fives
till Sunday."
"Then my fuckin' son stays,
motherfuckers, okay?"
And they let me graduate,
They let me finish out the year,
but you know what?
A nun never fuckin'
hit me again.
That's my story.
Thank you very much.
[dark electronic music]
♪